[Music]
hi I'm chef Dean Spiegel we're here at
the lobster place from Chelsea Market
and today we're going to learn how to
crack steamed lobster
I think lobster is held in a high regard
because it's a very visceral experience
using your hands for the most part you
know that's just a great way to eat
you're really in touch with your your
inner caveman so to speak some of the
mistakes people typically make with the
lobster they might overcook it for
cooking 100 at times so we might see it
for 13 minutes you're cooking it at home
you can boil it for like 10 minutes and
you're good to go so what I like to do
typically is to split the tail in half
I'm going to hold it steady with one
hand and then using a sharp knife force
it right down the middle of this come
down in one motion like that after we've
got the tail split typically what I like
to do is to crack the clogs I'm going to
sort of hold it out to the side like
that now I'm going to use the back of
the knife and just firmly lay the
SmackDown one time like this and then
you're going to sort of twist the knife
to the side and you can open the claw
out like that and then if you want you
can twist the towel off just sort of
rotate it to the side and then you've
got beautiful lobster tail right there
so you just pull the tail right out of
the shell you can dip it in butter if
you want you can just eat it straight up
once brave so sweet
right now summertime it's the best time
to enjoy lobsters they're good all year
round but right now you'll find that the
meat is super sweet you can switch the
whole knuckle off the body and then you
just open the claw out like that twist
the little claw out we use the claw and
the knuckle for lobster rolls I think
it's the most tender part sometimes if
you pull the head out here on the top of
the head you'll see like a little nugget
of meat right there even now that's an
insider difference there
you can eat that too that's good I'm a
bit of a hot mess right now and that's
kind of the way it's supposed to be so
that's acceptable I'm from the South
Shore of Long Island originally so I
grew up pretty close to water it was a
seafood restaurant in the town I grew up
in that I used to go to with my parents
and I used to order lobsters just
because I liked the utensils and the bib
and got whole you know getting all that
Ola gear on
I didn't really know what I was doing
and I usually had difficulty because I
was too young to understand it but once
I finally got the meat out and dipping
in that butter and there's nothing
better than really sweet Sandra lobster
meat
[Music]